>>> SENATE DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING
A PUSH FOR REPUBLICAN SUPPORT
NEEDED TO RESPECT THE RESPECT
FOR MARRIAGE ACT WHICH WOULD
CODIFY SAME-SEX MARRIAGE AND
THIS WOULD HAPPEN BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
IN AN OP-ED, THE COAUTHORS OF
THE RESPECT FOR MARRIAGE BILL
WROTE, THE BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION WOULD REPEAL THE
DEFENSE OF MARRIAGE ACT, A 1996
LAW THAT ALLOWED STATES AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO REFUSE TO
RECOGNIZE SAME-SEX MARRIAGES
PERFORMED IN OTHER STATES.
OUR BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION
LEAVES IN INTACT LAWS, IT WILL
NOT TAKE AWAY ANY LIBERTY OR
CONSCIOUS PROTECTIONS.
JOINING ME IS SENATOR TAMMY
BALDWIN FROM WISCONSIN.
THE EXCERPT I JUST READ YOU LEAN
INTO RELIGIOUS LIBERTY, WHAT DO
YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> AS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES, IN ORDER TO GET
THE SUPERMAJORITY NECESSARY TO
PASS THIS IN THE U.S. SENATE,
THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN RAISING.
A NEW LAW, DOES THAT CREATE SOME
NEW EXEMPTIONS.
AND THE ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY
NOT.
AND WHILE WE THINK IT IS CLEAR
AND SAID SO IN THE OP-ED, WE ARE
ENTERTAINING A CLARIFYING
AMENDMENT SO THAT ARGUMENT FALSE
FLAT AND WE CAN GET THE
NECESSARY NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS
TO JOIN ALL THE DEMOCRATS AND
PASS THE RESPECT FOR MARRIAGE
ACT.
>> HOW MANY REPUBLICANS DO YOU
HAVE AS YOU SIT HERE WITH ME
THIS MORNING?
>> WE'LL KNOW A LOT MORE BY THE
END OF THE DAY AS WE RECONVENE
AND DISCUSSIONS NOW VERY FOCUSED
ON THE DRAFT AMENDMENT, THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT, CONTINUE.
WE HAD JUST SHY OF 10, I THINK
FOR THE UNDERLYING BILL.
IF THIS CLARITY GETS SEVERAL
MORE WE'LL BE IN REALLY GOOD
SHAPE.
AND WE HOPE THAT WE'LL ACTUALLY
HAVE THE DEBATE AND PASSAGE OF
THE BILL NEXT WEEK.
>> BEFORE THE AMENDMENT YOU
WEREN'T OVER THE FINISH LINE?
>> I HAD FIVE ON THE RECORD AND
THREE MORE SOFT, NOT QUITE ON
THE RECORD.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL.
TO ME THIS ISN'T A POLITICAL
ISSUE, TO ME SUCCESS AND PASSING
IT FOR THE BENEFIT OF THOSE WHO
ARE IN SAME-SEX MARRIAGE OR
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE TO KNOW
THEY HAVE CERTAINTY.
SO MUCH HAS CHANGED IN RECENT
YEARS WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO BE MARRIED TO THE
PERSON YOU LOVE AND KNOW THAT
THAT MARRIAGE IS GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR YEARS TO COME.
>> ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT YOU
HEAR FROM REPUBLICANS IS WHY IS
THIS NECESSARY?
SUPREME COURT MADE SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE LEGAL IN ALL STATES
ALREADY.
WHY DO YOU NEED THIS?
>> WELL, THE SAME COURT THAT
OVERTURNED ROE V. WADE, PUTS IN
JEOPARDY A NUMBER OF OTHER
SUPREME COURT CASES, THE CASE
THAT AFFIRMED SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
THE CASE THAT AFFIRMED
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE
ARE MANY MILLIONS OF COUPLES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES WHO ARE
LEGITIMATELY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE -- ABOUT THE LEGITIMACY OF
THEIR MARRIAGE, ABOUT THE
CERTAINTY OF THEIR MARRIAGE.
YOU KNOW, WE OFTEN THINK WHEN WE
SAY THE WORD MARRIAGE OF THE
WEDDING RIGHTS.
BUT WITH A MARRIAGE CERTIFICATE
COMES VERY IMPORTANT RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT PEOPLE
RELY ON.
SAY HOSPITAL VISITATION AND, YOU
KNOW, ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO THIS IS TIMELY RIGHT NOW.
>> IS THERE ALSO SOMETHING ABOUT
AN ELECTED BODY VOTING AND
SAYING, I AFFIRM YOU.
WE AFFIRM YOU.
WE CHOOSE TO BELIEVE IN YOUR
RIGHT TO MAR MARRY.
>> I THINK THERE'S A STRONG
STATEMENT BUT LET'S REMIND
PEOPLE WHAT IS IN THE UNDERLYING
BILL.
IT REPEALS THE DEFENSE OF
MARRIAGE ACT, WHICH WAS AN ACT
OF A FORMER CONGRESS SAYING WE
DON'T RECOGNIZE SAME-SEX
MARRIAGES.
AND THE COURT OPINION MADE THAT
MOOT.
BUT TO REPEAL IT WOULD BE A VERY
AFFIRMING STATEMENT.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE FIVE SOLID
YESES THREE ON THE FENCE WAS
YOUR WISCONSIN REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUE RON JOHNSON ONE OF
THOSE EIGHT?
>> HE WAS IN THE BEGINNING.
BUT NOW I THINK THE -- WHAT I
HOPE IS HE'LL LOOK AT OUR
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT AND ACCEPT
IT AND GET BACK TO HIS ORIGINAL
POSITION.
BUT HE'S GONE BACK AND FORTH
QUITE A BIT ON THIS ISSUE.
>> WE HAVE SOUND OF SENATOR
JOHNSON RECENTLY SAYING THAT I
THINK HE'S OPPOSED TO IT.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> I SAID AT THIS POINT I DON'T
SEE A REASON TO OPPOSE IT TO GET
THEM OFF MY BACK.
I WOULD NOT SUPPORT IT IN THE
CURRENT STATE.
I AM NOT HAPPY WITH THE BALDWINS
OF THE WORLD OPENING UP THAT
WOUND AND THAT DEBATE.
>> HE SAID HE'S NOT HAPPY WITH
YOU FOR OPENING UP A WOUND.
>>, YOU KNOW, I THINK THOSE ARE
VERY UNFORTUNATE WORDS BUT WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS THIS IS A REAL
ISSUE TO MILLIONS OF COUPLES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS NOT BEING DONE FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
WE HAVE ALREADY A NICE
BIPARTISAN GROUP WORKING VERY
HARD TO PASS IT.
AND THIS IS ABOUT REALLY MOVING
FORWARD AND RECOGNIZING WHAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO IS
THAT YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO MARRY
THE PERSON YOU LOVE AND PROTECT
THEM WITH THE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AFFORDED BY
LAW.
>> YOU THINK THERE WILL BE A
SENATE VOTE THIS WEEK?
>> I THINK NEXT WEEK.
>> NEXT WEEK.
SENATOR BALDWIN THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US.